ready never do the copyright and it
makes me so mad okay
this episode is brought to you
exclusively by the Cash Shop everybody I
know is switching to the cash app and
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store they've introduced the cash
card and it's a new black debit card
that you can design yourself via the app
allowing you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want plus
it's the best way to pay people back
it's it's a homerun baby
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now
[Music]
it's the Christmas episode oh it's a
Christmas episode and we've got a
Christmas remix to the theme song from
congratulations
thanks mr. green legendary hip-hop
producer for helping us with that remix
he also does the regular version he's
done all three versions now so far the
guy is the hottest [ __ ] he's
absolutely one of my favorite producers
and it's so cool it's so cool that he
made the music and he keeps putting out
[ __ ] music for us at Green hip hop is
his Twitter and I believe it's his
instagram too and he he he also did the
chanc smith album a lot of you guys
probably don't know what chang smith is
but look it up i like that when it
brought to you by Gillette was that
that's like the baseball announcer guy
who is that what it is when he good
we've got yada yada
brought to you by I don't know Vin
Scully or some or whatever anyway it's
Christmas Merry Christmas how about when
people say Happy Christmas they decide
just just Dirks me just a little bit you
know just stick to what we [ __ ] use
how about Merry Christmas you don't need
to get cute with it happy Christmas my
producers tell me it's a British thing I
don't give a [ __ ] don't don't be British
when you're wishing a Merry Christmas
you say Merry Christmas Happy Christmas
well if you're American it's like the
guy who's going cheers because he went
to [ __ ] visit London for a weekend you
know Oh cheers mate cheers Cheers that's
awesome archers nah just say cool that's
what we do in America let's keep it
different let's keep the culture alive
let's keep this American culture alive
it's it's Christmas and you know you may
not be listening to it today but if you
are true baby if you listening to my
podcasts on Christmas here's the thing
either true baby or you Jewish okay
either true baby or you Jewish and and
we appreciate you listening me and one
fire
you know one fire appreciate you
listening so that's very cool
I I guess on Christmas man you know a
lot of people get lonely during the
holidays I actually feel some sense of
loneliness during the holidays and I
don't know why I don't know what it is
because I like it I like I don't like
the loneliness but I love Christmas and
I love Christmastime
and I seem like somebody who wouldn't
like it I seem like people you know
people always come could say to me like
oh you [ __ ] you hate everybody you're
you know it's really I don't do it I
don't I love people and I love families
they just people [ __ ] certain people
bore the [ __ ] out of me because most
people born and [ __ ] become come come to
the table with some real [ __ ] you know
but yeah I don't know i-i-i-i
but it's the Christmas episode and we're
gonna keep it Christmas themed but we're
not gonna do it just yet cuz you know I
still like to talk about what I want to
talk about and I just saw this [ __ ]
thing online which I knew the movie is
coming out but hey man
oceans 8 dude oceans 8th huh dude my
favorite thing is that like what did it
get to oceans not what was it first
Ocean's eleven than oceans twelve in the
13 and no 14 right I'll be hilarious
first of all I was like how high they
gonna go but it's so funny that like
they wanted to make him women version of
it and they didn't do the next big one
they did they were like well we'll get
eight you know like they didn't even do
[ __ ] ocean's 10 they were like how
many female movie stars do people give a
[ __ ] about and they were like oh at
least five and they were like well let's
you know let's see who and they were
like what's on your Bullock obviously
and then we're like Nicole Kidman and
they were like well she won't do it
she's real actress and they were like
okay Blanchett and they were like what
she won't do it she's real actress and
then came Fletch was like well how much
you can pay me and they were like oh oh
fifty billion dollars or however much
and there
like cool but they do have real
actresses in it like Cate Blanchett
Sandra Bullock she's real Anne Hathaway
had Elena Bonham Carter is [ __ ]
amazing you know Sarah Paulsen Oh Matt
Damon's in it that's cool
hey Matt Damon stop talking why does
this guy have to keep bringing up the me
to movement you know this guy it's like
hey man just shut up
III [ __ ] look I'm a Matt Damon fan I
go see his movies all the time I think
he's [ __ ] great actor but this guy
they'll be like how do you like your
pizza and he'll be like well you know
what enough about these [ __ ] guys
grow up in women what about the good
guys and you're like and and the guys
like uh I was looking for pepperoni
as the answer but god it's so it's so to
me it's so backwards it's so it's so
like like I'm all for you know feminism
great women deserve it's all everything
should be equal it should just be equal
we're all humans it should be equal
that's very obvious you got a dick or a
puss doesn't matter you're black you're
white ragin doesn't matter doesn't
matter equal everybody equal okay but
when you take a popular male franchise
and then say well let's make it equal
and make the female franchise the female
version of it first of all it's not
equal have women get their own [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] say Oh Ocean's eleven
all right let's make the all-female
Ocean's eleven that's already making it
not equal because it's the [ __ ]
that's the it should be you know [ __ ]
make it ten women who rob a bank but
don't call it oceans [ __ ] what a
oceans [ __ ] that's the guy [ __ ] it's
like it's like make it you know badass
chick bank robbers or whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call I mean that's the worst
title of all time you know what I mean
but like call it [ __ ] and so
so they got to they got to they got to
six stars I love how they got to six and
they were like well senator Bullock said
yes cate blanchett said yes Anne
Hathaway said yes Helena Bonham Carter
said yes Mindy Kaling's hot you know
she's hot right now she got the [ __ ]
huge show they were like yeah she's
great she's funny sure let's do it
they're like oh well you know Sarah
Paulson was on the oj thing that's great
she's a great actress yeah true true
okay cool cool okay so um you know what
Rihanna was in battleship and they were
like but yeah okay yeah yeah she's also
the bleh the biggest one of the biggest
pop stars right yeah yeah okay great
okay so what's that leave us that must
be eight that must be that must be nine
ten well what actually we're at what's
six oh [ __ ] okay
uh god that's six huh well yeah I guess
count it like Rihanna Suns really Cate
Blanchett in half the way I lean upon
him corner and then tangling that's six
and then they were like well no okay
it's seven because we said Sarah Paulson
oh yeah no right she did the OJ thing so
how do we get to a ever get to 14 well
we got that we're not even halfway there
you know what why don't we instead of
doing oceans 14 will do ocean's 10 I'll
be like uh you know what that would be
easier okay you sure we can't get Nicole
Kidman well no there's no way we can get
into calling it Kevin yeah it's true
it's true isn't a [ __ ] we can get on
how about I just thought of some female
stars
they're dead okay what about um and then
somebody was like you guys know some
critic he has no [ __ ] this Aquafina
girl and everyone was like there was a
big record scratch and everyone was like
huh don't drink like now it's good
because she's Asian too so we could
balance it out you know we've got Mindy
Kaling I was like 47 white chicks in it
so we got a like okay we got to [ __ ]
balance it out cool let's get her she's
Asian
and she's like a rapper okay cool sounds
good and then they were like let's make
it [ __ ] you know what let's just make
it and let's make it eight we'll make it
eight and there was like what we could
[ __ ] there I mean how could you [ __ ]
in and then they just stopped why eight
make it ten there's there's actually why
couldn't you [ __ ] make it Katie
Holmes is in it she's not one of the is
she one of the [ __ ] ain't no Dakota
Fanning she's in it she's not one of the
the whole [ __ ] movies ridiculous it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude like don't
make it ocean's 8 it's sexist make it
Ocean's eleven make it a [ __ ] new
thing you can't make it ocean's 8 and
say here we go women it's less women and
so people are I love how some people are
gonna be like well you only need less
women to do the job all right
you know what that's [ __ ] so many
women that aren't getting paid that all
these men got paid to do oceans [ __ ]
eleven Jennifer Lawrence she didn't do
it get her in it
give her [ __ ] thirty million dollars
and do it or get Jennifer Lawrence don't
get Aquafina and [ __ ] Rihanna oh man
so funny to me it's so funny to me that
they made oceans eight dude I wish they
made oceans forty forty women and it got
down to like women you saw in some
movies one few times like there was one
woman from a soap opera and an another
woman were you're like I think I just
seen that girl at my grocery store and
she was just like let's do this in the
produce section the fact that they
remade Ocean's eleven anyway is
ridiculous but here's the deal when
Hollywood remakes like apparently
Ocean's eleven the original version
which was with Frank Sinatra Dean Martin
Sammy Davis jr. Peter Lawford Joey
Bishop Angie Dickinson I mean everybody
would these pictures of black and white
you know it was the worst movie ever and
so at least remake the worst movie ever
that's what movies should be remade is
are the worst movie ever
don't remake good movies because they're
already good like when Steven Soderbergh
was like I'll make oceans live dude they
would never make that movie now because
of the climate they'd never make that
move if none of the oceans movies made
they'd never make that movie because
it's two male heavy anyway III was
talking about that I trailed off and
then my producer one fire [ __ ]
started pointing at something on the
table and it completely confuse me so I
got the room so one fire I'm gonna get a
new producer but um he was like pointing
and I was like you need to tell me
something he was like man and he was
like I never mind so anyways a [ __ ] and
one fire but um yeah it's a Christmas
episode dude oh [ __ ] for [ __ ] sake
[ __ ]
it's probably good I don't know I'm
[ __ ] Cate Blanchett is amazing in
senator Bullock it's [ __ ] one of the
best movie stars of all time so it's
probably [ __ ] good Thunder boys
[ __ ] hilarious actually
she's how long has she been acting 50
years and she still looks good I want to
be a
[ __ ] I want to be her I want to be a
chick like that
that's just [ __ ] badass for 40 years I
mean she was in oldies [ __ ] movies
member that love potion number nine
love potion notions nine um okay yeah
but it's Christmas coming up and or no
now I'm sorry
to all day coming up all day Christmas
brought to you by oceans eight what if
it was oceans [ __ ] two and it was
just [ __ ] Sandra Bullock and Chelsea
Handler walking around it was ocean it's
one Debbie ocean Sandra Bullock but yeah
this is gonna be a [ __ ] lackadaisical
episode and I don't give a [ __ ] dude
this is what you this is what it is
Christmas maybe a you know you are you
in another room right now you listening
you're with your family they're in the
other room and you're trying to [ __ ]
be cool and chill and you don't want to
be with them but you're just listening
to to this how about Christmas stories
and [ __ ]
you know like there's so [ __ ]
whenever Christmas stories are told you
have to tell them like this you can't
just be like guy you know I was Chris
night before Christmas and all [ __ ]
game and then all this [ __ ] happen and
the mouse couldn't even hear a mouse it
[ __ ] barely this [ __ ] all he could
hear is this and that and Christmas came
down and this [ __ ] happen and then
[ __ ] you heard the bell you know but
you gotta do it like this my producer
one fire pulled two Christmas stories
and I figured I'd read one or two to you
but you know in the first of all
commonly mistaken referred to as twas
the night before Christmas first of all
twas s [ __ ] it was the night before
Christmas or how about just call it the
night before Christmas calling it it was
the night before Christmas twas first of
all was dude I mean I know I talkin
drak can contractions his joke but this
[ __ ] is like some real [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] british dude with like all
that only wore brown and off light and
wrote with a feather and by like candle
light you know and one of those hats
that came over like this dude how about
in old times when people would wear
[ __ ] hats with their pajamas the [ __ ]
why would you wear a hat with your
pajamas you know I'm talking about the
guy who with the [ __ ] ball that comes
over who wears a hat who dude what if
you were dating a guy and as you're like
goodnight and then you're like all cool
and you and you're like yes but the
night and he's like let me just get my
PJs and he got in first of all the
[ __ ] matching top and bottoms and
then had the [ __ ] hat that hung over
dude I want to do that my next
relationship dude my next marriage
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna get
the hat that flaps over and be like
goodnight and then wear the hat to bed
that existed you know wearing a hat to
sleep dude what do you call that a night
[ __ ] that's not what you call it a
nightcap right it became known as the
[ __ ] drink would you like to adjourn
to my room for a nightcap you want me to
put a hat on no I never mind nightcap
dude I like to keep my head warm when
I'm sleep well I think it'd be cool if
you wore a nightcap but you just were a
[ __ ] Arizona Diamondbacks baseball
hat d-backs
alright so yeah so that's what he wrote
that he wrote that [ __ ] [ __ ] and his
name of it's called a visit from st.
Nicholas which is the what was what this
story's actually called by here we go
dude turn your [ __ ] British down a
little bit turn your
British volume down I don't give a [ __ ]
if this guy was american or not he's
british because his name is Clement
Clarke Moore Clemente is it Clement or
Clemente they set it in between one fire
he goes Clement Clement can you play
music while I do it
what for mood okay do it you change it
for something else
Oh like when you play it oh cool well I
don't need it for me then [ __ ] guy
trying to you know [ __ ] do all the
[ __ ] you want music like chill dude just
[ __ ] make sure the headphones work
you know headphones weren't charged
today by the way they weren't [ __ ]
charged that he's got [ __ ] one job
he's like you want some music or don't
let it subject [ __ ] one fire for dude
you want some [ __ ] music for you and
then I'll added some in later I what the
[ __ ] am I
you know like I'm gonna be all overcome
with the Christmas spirit and just twas
the night before Christmas dude twas the
night before Christmas so here's what it
is a visit from st. Nicholas by Clement
Clarke Clemente Clarke more yeah three
first names on a more I guess isn't twas
the night before Christmas when all
through the house not a creature was
stirring not even a mouse what year was
this written
I don't like how it rhymes already it's
stupid to make it rhyme I don't like
when you fit in it when you got to fit
in some [ __ ] it's a limerick the whole
thing rhymes when was it written 1823
dude every song written or store not
Stiga says in the story but is said to
me it's a song cause it rhymes every
song written by 1823 that [ __ ] give this
song a [ __ ] a hundred years in him
you gotta burn it can't listen to it
anymore
you know twas the night before Christmas
when all through the house not a
creature was stirring not even a mouse
the stockings were hung by chimney with
care in hopes that st. Nicholas soon
would be there kind of basic you know
and care with their like everything's so
proper like not a creature was stirring
not even a mouse
he was tearing stockings were hung like
he didn't say that the hunk we had hung
stockings but the chimney with care and
then in hopes that st. Nicholas soon
would be there
like it so loses its allure if you're
just like in hopes that st. Nicholas
soon would be there
instead of be there I don't like you
know
the children were nestled all snug in
their beds so creepy while visions of
sugarplums danced in their head the [ __ ]
is a sugar plum what is the sugar plum
and Mama in kerchief and I in my cap
that straight-up is some [ __ ] Kodak
black would say mama in her kerchief and
I'm a cat oh so he's wearing is my cap
had just settled our Brit and settled
our brains for a long winters nap yo so
he was they do sleep in their night caps
they sleep in their cabs that's so
stupid also this sucks you know this
story [ __ ] sucks
this [ __ ] blows chunks dude like when
out on the lawn then there arose such a
clatter and just say arose a clatter
such a clatter I sprang from my bed to
see what was the matter anyway are away
to the window I flew like a flash tore
open the shutters and threw up the sash
this sucks
[Music]
getting super V right here the moon on
the breast of the new-fallen snow like
couldn't help it you know with such a
pair of Clement Clement Clarke Moore was
like I'll get mentioned titties I gotta
[ __ ] I got a reference titties a
little bit I'll talk about the moon's
titties gave a luster of midday to
objects below talking about his [ __ ] you
know when what to my wandering eyes did
appear but a miniature sleigh and eight
tiny reindeer a miniature sleigh
I mean it was smaller than normal cause
it was far away no he's talking about on
top of his house maybe this guy just a
little drop to acid and he's like oh
yeah
it was small it's like that [ __ ] the
end of a Mahal and drive when the little
old people come out of the [ __ ] box
and David Lynch movie an eight tiny
reindeer why are they tiny that's weird
I thought they were all regular shits
it's far away
he's seeing it faraway there's too many
extra words in this just say you saw the
[ __ ] sleigh and eight reindeer
they're not tiny they're just far away
with a little old driver so lively and
quick I knew in a moment he must be
Saint Nick no you knew now dude you
can't know something
oh well no I guess you could he's like
but we he's telling us he knew he would
it was about to know in the moment that
Emily more rapid than Eagles his courses
his coursers they came and he whistled
and shouted and called them by name now
Dasher now dancer now Prancer and vixen
on comet on Cupid on Dom Donner on
Blitzen [ __ ] worst names ever dancer
you know to the top of the porch to the
top of the wall at little jump now dash
away dash away dash away all this
[ __ ] sucks dude it's so long it's
[ __ ] shitty dude it's ended and then
he gave presents and then I got presents
and then I took my nightcap off and woke
up look at this it's too [ __ ] it's in
a whole nother [ __ ] page of rhyming
and then more
[Music]
like look how boring as leaves that
before the wild Hurricane Fly when they
meet with an obstacle mount to the sky
so up to the housetop the coursers they
flew with the sleigh full of toys and
st. Nicholas - this sucks
his eyes how they twinkled his dimples
how merry his dimples how merry I'm
going for the stump of a pipe he held
tight like stop describing him you
[ __ ] what do you want to [ __ ] him his
belly so round his cotton like a nub I
couldn't believe it I wanted to give it
a rub his red little nose I needed to
warm it in my mouth I sucked on his nose
while I judged his [ __ ] stop describing
a [ __ ] fat old guy I gave it a tug
played with his thighs turned out he
liked it I could see by his eyes his
reindeers watched in wonder then I
[ __ ] sat on the toilet and I made him
give me a blumpkin
I [ __ ] while st. Nick sucked on my [ __ ]
then he gave me presents in my mouth so
creepy he's just watching some old guy
doll get his even know it to it the old
guy doesn't even know it you know and
he's talking about animals they were
tiny tiny animals with a tiny sleigh
made his [ __ ] look bigger yay look at
this he was chubby and plump how [ __ ]
fetish he is this [ __ ] he was chubby and
plump I came on his feet I laughed
a wink of his eye and a twist of his
head right there sounds like he came on
his face soon gave me to know I had
nothing to dread what this is getting
weird he spoke not a word but went
straight to his work and filled all the
stockings then turned with a jerk I mean
that's actually how it goes like uh this
sounds honestly like this story sounds
like Santa came by had work to do and
gave [ __ ] Clemente Clark Moore a nice
quick [ __ ] and then was like we're not
mentioning this to anybody and then
finished it give him presents to
everybody else
[Music]
what a gamy presence what a beautiful
favor and then left really quick so he
can [ __ ] the next a neighbor that's part
of it no that [ __ ] story sucks dude
I don't lie you know what sucks is like
stories were cool when they were cool
and then the times change and the Styles
change let's just all agree that story
sucks donkey dick you know we have to
act like it's all tradition did my dad
used to make us [ __ ] listen to the
Polar Express
he used to [ __ ] to make us do it I
was up until I was like 20 he was like
will you always do it and it became a
thing for him he was like I like to do
with you guys and I'd have to sit there
with my [ __ ] Abercrombie & Fitch
jeans like I was an adult for [ __ ]
sake and I had to sit and watch [ __ ]
my dad read The Polar Express and he'd
turned those big-ass pages [ __ ] those
big pages man make the pages as big as
they need to [ __ ] be how about when
you're reading [ __ ] this is for the
video but when you're reading the
[ __ ] Polar Express and you're like
and he couldn't hear the bell and it's
one sentence and then your life but the
other kid could and the train came on
the station and then you're moving the
[ __ ] page like it's the [ __ ] tarp
when it rains at Shea Stadium all right
add time babies Square cash it mean look
you know what the [ __ ] square cash is
you [ __ ] [ __ ] look crash-up
is the number one finance app in the App
Store maybe it's because it's the best
way to people back I don't know do you
think setting and receiving money is
totally free and fast on most payments
can be deposited directly to your bank
account in seconds here's how it works
download the square cash app link your
debit or a credit card select an amount
to send and type in a friend's phone
number or email it
to complete a payment and they'll get a
notification they've just received money
that's it no gimmicks Square cash is
good it doesn't list the [ __ ] fee is
stuff you know it's like I hate when you
when you pay for something for somebody
and it lets you know that they're like
oh yeah I paid this guy for like a gift
it's like they don't need to know my
business square cash keeps a private man
it's nice I love it
as a new black debit card that you can
design yourself it's called the cash
card a cash card allows you to use the
cash that you keep in the app anywhere
you want you'll get notifications for
all payments made with the card directly
via the cash app cash app team is
constantly building a new feature so
what are you doing using the other guys
get cash app today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now have yourself a merry little
Christmas may your days be [ __ ]
bright nobody knows the next line of
that you know where's the other [ __ ]
story we had that one was so bad visit
from st. Nicholas and here we go first
of all it's called a Christmas hamper by
anonymous here's the other thing too if
you don't know who wrote it let's just
that's it for that story you know I
understand Clement Clarke Moore what he
did was he [ __ ] wrote a classic
Christmas song there's something to be
said for that as much as I think it
[ __ ] blows donkey dicks it's [ __ ]
good that he did that and he shaped the
culture good job dude but he did it more
than I'm doing it I ain't [ __ ] compared
to this [ __ ] but uh if we forget
who wrote it like you know that's the
whole deal like okay he wrote it so we
got to give him credit that's the guy
who did that if you don't know who wrote
this [ __ ] [ __ ] don't have it on
the Internet look at how it began let's
get in the beginning a Christmas hamper
it's called worst title of all time
would be so boring it's about a hamper
the Christmas hamper neaten trim is full
of sweet things to the brim its tails
and rhymes and pictures bright will
please your dear on Christmas night that
[ __ ] sucks
that [ __ ] sucks that's the beginning
of it and that's one-eighth of it that
sucks
hey man whoever wrote that that's Kodak
black wrote that that's the sound cloud
wrappers now sound cloud wrappers wrote
a Christmas hamper all right yeah let's
do it let's do the Christmas tree we
asked you guys on the congratulations
podcast Twitter some Christmas [ __ ]
questions to keep it Christmas food hmm
and yeah this guy wrote Gus at T gust of
wind he wrote how about how we dinner at
2:00 p.m. on holidays whoops it's not in
time that's funny dude
that's so that's weird it's weird
because you wake up what is that I
actually didn't know that that was a
thing that a lot of people did I know my
family doesn't I guess I do know a lot
of families to do that but like yeah we
eat at 4:00 or some [ __ ] which is still
too early what are we [ __ ] 78 but
it's funny because like you know you
don't you eat it [ __ ] up your whole day
you wake up you either wake up too early
or too late on Christmas you never wake
up at like 9:00 you know you wake up at
6:00 cuz you're like oh I'm getting
presents you wake up at 11 cuz you're
like [ __ ] this day I get to sleep in
9:00 is nothing or 8:30 you know but um
eat dinner at 2 p.m. is funny do it cuz
you got to wake up and then you got to
have like an egg or two or like a little
bit of granola cuz you know you're gonna
[ __ ] go to somebody's house and you
know the cooking and what you want to be
hungry that's an IE 20 that's what I do
you got to do that when people go like
this when people say like this when
they're like oh no I don't want to eat
because I'm eaten later
that's unbelievable to me
that's unbelievable if foods in front
and you're like nah
supposed to go to dinner later you're
hungry now [ __ ] you could get
hit by a car in 30 minutes
eat when you're hungry that that's so
weird to me dude if you want to eat now
eat now
dude that's a problem in the world man
you got to [ __ ] do more what you want
I
I hate being inspirational but this
podcast if we go if you've got one
underlying thing do what the [ __ ] you
want when you want it dude it's so
annoying a people or leiden you know I
used to be like that too cuz when I was
a you know you listen to your parents no
don't eat you're gonna [ __ ] we're
supposed to go out you know we're having
good food okay why can't I eat this
[ __ ] Palio string cheese now you're
gonna ruin your appetite no I'm not
[ __ ] this is my appetite I want it
now it's what I want now I gotta wake
cuz we're going to [ __ ] whoever's
house to eat [ __ ] you know to eat a
some [ __ ] like quiche I keeps like one
twice you go to these holiday ampulla
how about you eating [ __ ] up [ __ ]
tonight today you're definitely some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that you never eat whoo
what's this oh it's a sausage [ __ ]
loaf huh what's in it sausage bread
crumbs and then we there's jalapenos and
it and we pour coffee in it and then
also there's fun dip it's sprinkled with
fun dip and and the second you take a
bite you're going to want to evacuate
your bowels
oh cool Merry Christmas let me taste it
oh my god let me taste it gotta go you
gotta eat it on the toilet that's the
thing about this [ __ ] sausage loaf
so anyway go up what was the other one
okay
favor is so Emily Dumas favorite
Christmas film here's what that makes me
think of by the way why does it do this
try it
favorite Christmas film and then under
it translate from German Twitter
hey Twitter get your [ __ ] [ __ ]
together favorite Christmas up
translated from German what does it say
go ahead hit it unbelievable
it's his favorite Christmas film and
then it says translate from German and
then you write then he hit it and I
wrote could not translate tweet trans
translated by Bing hey Bing get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] together the other day I
tried to translate something that said
something about my name on Twitter from
Bing and it was something that was like
in Asian language I can't remember which
one and then it was even more
unintelligible I put on my Instagram
favourite Christmas film I don't know
man my dad loves watching black and
white [ __ ] dude he loves watching It's a
Wonderful Life he loves watching
anything black and white man I'll get
over Christmas and they'll be like I
just like when it's on and [ __ ] Bing
Crosby he'll be sick I like when it's on
in the background you ever hear this guy
and it would be like who's singing there
I don't know you know you don't know who
[ __ ] sudsy Wales is or some [ __ ]
what are those [ __ ] names and they
were younger Bing Crosby Bing is that
who's translating is that why he doesn't
know
Bing Bing Crosby [ __ ] Adam Bing D'Elia
from now on suds
[ __ ] buh-buh-buh be yeah you know who
sings that song sudsy sudsy [ __ ]
Philips and he's like Pat that down a
puppet yeah Baba whatever to that style
nobody sings like that anymore
bad bad bad and I wrap that badly
Christmastime yippity-do your band
slipping and falling Christmastime bring
the tree and get bit bit how many times
is this a bit bit bit in [ __ ] songs
in like the 30s and my dad be like I
just like it it's not in the background
I do I it's Christmas [ __ ] that I can
sing like that I don't give a [ __ ]
that's good yeah it's good I do ye t woo
it's Christmas we never talk about cheer
except for Christmas time um favourite
Christmas film I don't know you know I
would say what is a Christmas from a
Christmas ohm is a film that takes place
during Christmas and makes you feel
Christmassy when you watch it but
sometimes I play Christmas films in June
unlike HBO which is [ __ ] weirdest
[ __ ] but they'll do it makes no sense
but I would say I owe you know my
favorite Christmas movie is [ __ ]
what's the one is it called jingle all
the way with almost forcing her and
Sinbad that one they're good to get the
tip a man on his horse [ __ ] trying to
get dude Sinbad is [ __ ] hilarious
he's trying to get turbo man and Sinbad
plays a mailman and he's trying to get
the turbo man
the last turbo man and they [ __ ]
basically it's like a fight to the death
it's so funny dude that movie I'm gonna
watch a movie and [ __ ] laugh and then
I was watching in June I also like
diehard and here's the thing it bugs me
when people ask if it's a Christmas
movie because it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter that's the answer that
question on the it became a thing on the
Internet
like one of those things that people
like to talk about like how good is
Pizza is Chris diehard at a [ __ ]
Christmas movie here's the answer to
that it doesn't [ __ ] matter it
doesn't matter you watch the [ __ ]
movie and you can watch a movie in March
and then also watch in Christmas and you
can actually feel Christmassy
so yeah it's of course was what we were
watching it at Christmas if not you're
not watching it Christmas it's not a
Christmas movie but diehard is one of my
favorite action movies of all time I
mean it might be number one it might be
number one it's great I love it it's so
good Bruce Willis is a great action hero
he's a great action here he's also a
good actor but he's a great action hero
because look I love the rock more than
the just as much as the next guy and I
love I love Jason Statham I'm a big fan
of both of those guys I love those guys
but there's something about the [ __ ]
Bruce Willis generation where he was
like that he was like fit but he wasn't
buff I like [ __ ] when action movie
stars are not the biggest guys in the
movies because it's more relatable and
you and it's like you it's just cooler
to me Keanu Reeves that in speed was a
great one it was great casting it was I
love that movie but he was just like a
guy and fit and cool and definitely an
alpha and you believed him with a gun
but he wasn't like this hulking guy who
[ __ ] deadlifts 8,000 pounds you know
and that's what the rock is and that's
fine and that's what semester Stallone
was too an honor for Snyder of course
but those guys who like in the 80s and
90s like like Kurt Russell was a great
one to me [ __ ] just not overly buff
yeah Chuck Norris it was ridiculous but
that one you know I mean it's different
when they know like martial arts because
that's more about that look at the
martial arts films like they don't
really make those anymore they make them
but they're not like big hits like I
mean yes Jason kind of like that but not
really but like even like they don't
like what's his name on was that one
that didn't move Owen Wilson Jackie Chan
like dad those those movies don't really
exist anymore do they
like Jet Li and [ __ ] they don't only
make those anymore that are like they're
not big hits you know yeah best present
I've ever given best present you've ever
received by at Beasley Kelly I don't
[ __ ] know worst gift I ever gave was
my gave my dad an audiobook once because
I didn't know what to give him and it
was like some [ __ ] I just really
liked the audiobook so I just picked one
out we just have to wait at the top of
the stairs to uh I used to have I used
to have to wait at the top of stairs
with my brother get ready cause he was
smaller and [ __ ] and you'd be like wait
for your brother we're walking down and
see the gifts under the tree let's stand
abroad at the same time and then Matt
used to have a head start and there's
one video that we have from like VHS and
were like Matt's walking through the
doorway and I walk past him and I bump
him and he hits his head on the side of
the door and [ __ ] it's so funny
because he doesn't stop smiling cuz he's
looking at the presence we always
[ __ ] that we always [ __ ] talk
about that every Christmas when I
[ __ ] zipped past Matt when I passed
Matt and I [ __ ] bumped his head into
the doorway and he literally just went
huh because he was looking at the
presents he was looking at the [ __ ]
Thundercats layer that we got or
whatever the [ __ ] mm-hmm
best gift I ever got how annoying is it
when when people like best gift I ever
got my family oh really we're talking
about [ __ ] [ __ ] that cost stuff
best gift I ever got I don't know mm-hmm
I don't know I always feel like the best
gifts are the gifts that you don't that
you wouldn't get you wouldn't buy
yourself and you don't necessarily need
it but somebody gets it for you and it's
like oh it's cool I have that now
because I would never buy that but it's
[ __ ] it adds to my life like I don't
know what is like that but like like
like a [ __ ] I don't know like a like
a like I guess thoughtful gifts are
really good though
like [ __ ] Oh like I love [ __ ]
shoes if somebody got me like a [ __ ]
shoe [ __ ] rack or some [ __ ] you know
that'd be a good gift for me like I mean
I already have all that [ __ ] but I'm
just saying like I don't know it's hard
to get gifts man or when people say what
do you get the guy who has everything
you know you have to [ __ ] think you
got to think dude a sundial I make
everybody a sundial I make it my gifts
framed stuff is a good gift always but
then you got to go to the store and do
it and it's an errand it's like I just
want to order [ __ ] online from Amazon
I'm good I pretty much got all my gift
giving stuff out of the way gift
shopping stuff out of the way it is
Christmas so I usually do it after
Christmas I get I wrap them up and I put
them in pictures and I [ __ ] and I say
that's what you're getting in in three
days you'll get that it'll be here by
the 28th and then it doesn't come and
then it comes after New Year's and then
I forget to give it to him the next time
I see them and then they get it by
February 2nd here it is and it's like
stale cookies are they they were they
were fresh on Christmas
um what another question when you get a
present you just like do you pretend to
like it or make fun of it immediately
Brandon at Brandon
uh I like III it depends on the
relationship if it's somebody I don't
really know I go how cool oh nice yeah
oh that's [ __ ] a that's a good gift
nice thank you man
but if it's somebody I know I'm like the
[ __ ] am I gonna use this for dude
and I [ __ ] pull down my pants and I
rub my [ __ ] all over it whatever
what if Clement Clarke Moore had a
Twitter how [ __ ] [ __ ] would it be you
know be all Ryan [ __ ] alright I don't
know this can be a short episode you
gotta go be with your family anyway but
I appreciate you guys listening on
Christmas and if you need to get gifts
for somebody still go on the [ __ ]
website crystally accom go to the store
and get him some [ __ ] baby [ __ ] uh
here's another thing about Christmas
eggnog [ __ ] sucks never tasted it
won't ever taste it no it sucks catch
you later
oh it's creamy catch you later Oh egg
hey what's grosser than drinking
something with the word egg in it
something with the word nog in it eggnog
there's also one of those words where
you can't help but add a third syllable
even though it's not there eggnog it's
like you become completely [ __ ]
Japanese hey what you guys drink an egg
on Olga um alright square cast have you
switched yet you [ __ ] you got a
switch download the free square cash app
design your cash card and get it for iOS
or Android now do it dude thanks for
listening to the Christmas episode we
hope your day has been filled with lots
of Cheers
and to all the babies out there we hope
you have a wonderful Christmas and the
next episode who knows when it's going
to be pretty in a week in about a week
because mondays are hitting holidays and
we got to [ __ ] Bank these episodes
man but uh we
[ __ ] you listenin and you guys are the
best dude some of you I'm sure a lot of
[ __ ] killers listen to this there's
we get a lot of downloads and listens to
this definitely somebody who's killed
somebody listens to this and if you have
killed somebody you know who you are if
you're listening and I want you tell I
want to tell you don't [ __ ] do that
again do not kill anybody again and
don't [ __ ] don't do sexual assault
and don't do [ __ ] property damage
don't do those things don't do those
things don't do noise pollution [ __ ]
chill you know who you are if you've
done noise pollution
you know you know it's pollution alright
guys rate review the show that's some
you know what you can do dude my crisps
for my Christmas for my present you can
rate review the show that's what you can
do would really appreciate that thank
you my babies you guys are awesome
talk to you later see ya and remember
eggnog [ __ ] socks and remember